[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ses idées qui gouvernent
le monde quel avenir pour la
social-démocratie
l'histoire du socialisme en france n'est
pas un long fleuve tranquille quant à la
social-démocratie un concept
politiquement et juridiquement flou et
qui cherchent à conjuguer la démocratie
sociale à la démocratie politique
elle se porte à peine mieux si on
considère que six pays de l'union
européenne s'en réclament il était plus
du double il y a deux décennies la
spécificité du socialisme français comme
par ailleurs d'autres partis sociaux
démocrates européens vient de la
scission opérée il ya un siècle au
congrès de tours en une branche
collectiviste le parti communiste est
une branche réformiste l'ess est fiable
ou mist opposé au léninisme et au
bolchévisme le parti socialiste est
aujourd'hui l'objet d'une espèce dopé a
opéré par jean luc mélenchon et la
france insoumise sur l'ensemble de la
gauche et des écologistes
un rassemblement de gauche a pu être
opéré dans le passé notamment par léon
blum et le front populaire le programme
commun de françois mitterrand la gauche
plurielle de lionel jospin
l'élection de françois hollande en 2012
mais à chaque fois ce fut sous
leadership social démocrate en 2022
c'est clairement contre trois revers de
la social démocratie que la nouvelle
union de la gauche dite nubes s'est
constitué avec pour mentor jean luc
mélenchon de cette déconstruction
politique qu'il faut bien sûr
contextualisés par rapport aux
évolutions et aux crises mondiales et
aussi de l'élection et de la réélection
des manuels macron nous allons débattre
et notamment de l'avenir de la social
démocratie en france et en europe je
vous présente mes invités françois
hollande inutile vous présenter mais
merci chaleureusement d'avoir accepté
notre invitation pour ce débat
david jez merci d'être là vous êtes haut
fonctionnaire et essayiste hélène
geoffroy vous êtes maire de vaulx en
velin et vous êtes ancien ministre
nicolas baverez s vous êtes historien et
économiste
[Musique]
alors commençons par l'actualité
l'avenir du parti socialiste vous
paraît-il définitivement compromis de
part sa compromission d'ailleurs c'est
le thème le terme bardon utilisé par
carole delga et de nombreux hiérarques
socialistes
avec jean luc mélenchon qu'est ce que
vous en pensez françois hollande
la direction du parti socialiste actuel
a fait un choix qui est d'aller vers la
france a soumises pour se présenter
ensemble aux élections législatives dans
le cas d'un hâle corps électoral qui
écarte
des socialistes dans 500 5 500
circonscription ce choix mon avis est un
choix qui est à la fois tactique
permettre une représentation un certain
niveau parlement mais est un choix aussi
idéologique qui conduit cette direction
a adhéré à un programme qui n'est pas
puisque c'est le thème de votre
entretien sociale démocrate ou
socialiste tel qu'on l'entend telle
qu'on l'entendait tant qu'il y aura un
moment où sans doute après les élections
législatives une clarification devra
s'opérer de savoir si cette orientation
est suivi les faits donc se poursuit
sous le label de la france a soumises ou
de la nuque ou si au contraire il y a
une identité socialiste qui demeure eh
bien ça ce sera aux militants
socialistes pour ce qu'il en reste et ou
sympathisants socialistes ses électeurs
socialistes de le déterminer et je crois
si vous voulez mon point de vue qu'il y
à une nécessité pas pour des vieilles
maisons comme léon blum face à
l'offensive du parti communiste
en 1920 mais et non pour permettre que
la france puisse avoir une vie choix
aujourd'hui ce choix d'une certaine
façon est
imposé puisque les français ont un côté
et la gauche radicale de l'autre le pôle
central où le pôle de centre-droit comme
on voudra à la partie aisée donc je
pense qu'il est nécessaire que la gauche
celle qui a vocation à gouverner se
reconstitue au lendemain des élections y
met ce que vous reprenez françois
hollande le mot compromission les mots
ont un sens et dans compromission il ya
une dimension morale
est-ce que vous reprenez c'est ce terme
là c'est à dire que c'est une conduite
immorale que d'un non je ne me place pas
du tout sur le terrain de la morale je
me passe sur le terrain de de l'histoire
et aussi de la crédibilité d'une force
socialiste l'histoire c'est de pouvoir
être une gauche qui puisse demain
gouverneuse qui appelle nécessairement
une prise en compte de la réalité et
puis aussi je me place sur le terrain de
l'avenir parce que le pays a besoin
d'une alternance cette alternance ne
peut pas venir ou d'une gauche trop
radicale celle qui s'est constituée
autour de jean luc mélenchon ou autour
de l'extrême droite qu'il est nécessaire
que le mouvement socialiste puisse
perdurer à condition qu'ils se
renouvellent parce que si c'est pour
reproduire ce qui a été fait qui était
tout à fait honorable y compris sous mon
propre sous ma propre autorité
ce n'est pas la peine et le monde évolue
la question écologique est devenu majeur
la question des inégalités méritent
d'être traitées on a redécouvert le rôle
la place des services publics et aussi
de ce que peut apporter l'europe vous
dit qu'elle est gouvernée simplement par
six
anciens gouvernements socialistes c'est
plus large et il ya aussi des haltes à
lens qui se feront dans ces pays qui
permettent ce que l'europe garde c'est
justement un modèle social original dans
lequel les socialistes ont une grande
part à jouer et c'est une des raisons de
divergences par rapport à ce qui s'est
fait autour de jean luc mélenchon c'est
la question européenne n'ont pas comment
on va rentrer et on va rentrer dans le
détail des différences désobéir à la
construction européenne c'est d'une
certaine son rompre avec l'histoire de
la social-démocratie hélène geoffroy
vous avez l'avantagé ou l'inconvénient
de représenter la tendance sociale
démocrate au parti socialiste alors est
ce que vous vous estimez que c'est une
compromission que j'ai tenus baisse moi
j'ai plutôt parler en pour la direction
nationale d'une forme de reddition c'est
à dire que dans les formes d'union de la
gauche que vous avez cités 1 qui ont
permis une fois au pouvoir ont permis je
le rappelle parce que c'est l'enjeu de
la social-démocratie transformer la
société mais aussi la vie quotidienne
des habitants de notre pays c'est que
elle s'est faite autour d'une
construction autour d'idées de projets
de programmes ce à quoi nous avons
assisté c'est plutôt j'ai parlé de
reddition c'est à dire que la direction
nationale est rentré dans le programme
porté par jean luc mélenchon sent à
négocier et ni les contourner la forme
des le font en réalité ça aurait dû se
faire avec une négociation non moi je ne
suis je ne partage pas cette tendance
vers la gauche radicale mais jusqu'à
présent chaque fois que la gauche à
gérer ensemble les forces de gauche
venus d'horizons différents ont
travaillé ensemble et c'est le cas quand
on le fait aussi sur nos territoires au
niveau local c'est que nous travaillons
un projet un programme d'abord alors là
nous sommes face à une rupture de toute
notre histoire fait en quinze jours sans
aucune consultation des militants je
rappelle aussi que la force de la social
démocratie et du parti socialiste c'est
sa démocratie interne c'est ce qui nous
différencie des mouvements tourner
autour d'une personne c'est que nous
nous avons la force des idées et dans ce
cadre là ce qui s'est passé c'est que
nous avons que la direction nationale a
absorbé a été programme de jean luc
mélenchon tout en disant
dans dans certains cercles il était peu
facilement réalisables sur certains
aspects mais nicolas baverez et david
gest vous êtes des observateurs avisés
de la vie politique française est ce
qu'à votre avis ce compromis nubes est
fondamentalement différent des alliances
que j'ai c'est signalé que ce soit le
front populaire que ce soit l'élection
de mitterrand que ce soit l'élection de
françois hollande c'est ce que ça se
serait constitué plus démocratiquement
nicolas baverez sinon je crois qu'il ya
une e il ya une vraie différence d'abord
il faut rappeler que cette décision
c'est le résultat aussi de de résultats
très mauvais du parti socialiste à
l'élection présidentielle
avec
d'abord monsieur hamon et puis ensuite
anne hidalgo qui a fait un score très
faible c'est aussi l'évolution de ce
qu'on a vu au premier tour c'est à dire
d'un paysage politique est complètement
bouleversée avec l'effondrement des
partis de gouvernement traditionnels et
trois grands blocs est une vraie
aspiration par ailleurs des électeurs de
gauche à une forme à une forme d'union
donc
c'est vrai que jean luc mélenchon a très
habilement profité de ce moment pour
asseoir son leadership et comme vous
l'avez rappelé c'est quelque chose qui
est très différente qui s'est fait par
le par le passé alors néanmoins ce qu'il
faut quand même rappeler c'est que le la
gauche sociale démocrate ou la gauche
réformiste a généralement été
minoritaire on l'a rappelé léon blum a
été mise en minorité au congrès de tours
ensuite il avait été durement attaqué
par les néo qui était plutôt partie du
côté identitaire extrême droite dans les
années 30 ensuite pierre mendès-france
en réalité gagné sur son nom les
élections de 1956 mais ça n'est pas lui
qui a accédé au pouvoir et puis ensuite
michel rocard également a été mis en
minorité donc il y a quand même il faut
toujours rappeler que c'est une vraie
innovation dans notre histoire mais ce
qui n'est pas une innovation dans
l'histoire c'est que la gauche française
reste intellectuellement sous l'emprise
de la gauche la plus radicale et que ça
envoie à une histoire très longue
jusqu'à la révolution où le radicalisme
révolutionnaire a laissé une empreinte
une empreinte extrêmement forte ce qui
explique la force du marxisme dans la
vie politique française durant tout le
20e siècle est ce qui explique que jean
luc mélenchon a réactivé un certain
nombre de clivage qui sont des clivages
très fort dans notre histoire et dans
l'histoire de la gauche française alors
david gest qu'est ce que vous en pensez
et j'ai une appréciation un peu
différente le score de jean luc
mélenchon au premier tour de la
présidentielle il ya un socle
effectivement de 8 à 10% d'électeurs qui
sont l'extrême gauche marxiste la france
et je crois le seul pays d'europe de
l'ouest tourner à deux candidats
trotskistes qui sont systématiquement
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
avec les 500 signatures le réseau de
militants et c'est donc ça c'est vrai
que c'est une spécificité française en
revanche je pense que dans l'électorat
de jean luc mélenchon il ya une partie
significative de militants ou
d'électeurs de gauche démocrates
parfaitement républicains modérés qui
sont sincèrement désespérée de l'état de
désunion extrême d'inconsistance dans
lequel se trouve la gauche et qui ont
privilégié au fond la tactique c'est à
dire l'union sur les idées maintenant et
qu'est ce que vous pensez du car qui est
appelé à voter pour marine le pen à
droite qui est hétérogène radicalement
hétérogènes à la gauche c'est un vote
populiste chimiquement populiste qui
peut se porter indifféremment sur des
candidatures antisystème radical après
je pense qu'il faut essayer de
comprendre cette situation sert comment
on en est arrivé là je pense que un
journaliste américain m'a appelé ya pas
longtemps désormais pourquoi la gauche
de gouvernement est elle aussi aussi
effondré en france c'est vrai qu'elle
traverse une crise partout en europe de
l'ouest s'est lié à la mondialisation
s'est dit assez grand à ces grands
phénomènes qu'on n'a pas forcément su
traiter de la bonne manière mais en
france c'est vraiment un état depuis
2007 d'inconsistance qui est très fort
et je pense que c'est lié à une
trajectoire historique française de la
gauche est résumé par deux dates 81 et
83 circuit en 1981 françois mitterrand
arrive au pouvoir après avoir construit
un accord politique avec le parti
communiste un programme qui est
extrêmement vigoureux qui ressemble un
peu au programme de la libération
d'ailleurs avec des nationalisations
avec une relance très forte par la
demande des choses qui ont pas toujours
très bien fonctionné d'ailleurs et puis
en 1983 il ya ce virage qui est qu'on a
appelé le tournant de la rigueur une
politique de désinflation compétitive et
puis des socialistes qui se sont engagés
certains gaiement d'ailleurs dans la
voie de la mondialisation de la
construction européenne parfois centraux
d'esprit critique et je pense qu'en
france en fait on est un peu prisonnier
de cette alternative entre de gauche qui
n'ont pas suffisamment travaillé pas
suffisamment réfléchi aux enjeux du
moment une gauche de 80 qui restait très
étatiste très auto-centrée très bon on
va tout régler par la dépense publique
très secteurs publics une gauche de 83
qui a vu le monde en train de changer
mais qui à mon avis est trop partie
justement dans la pièce mans au
néolibéralisme et à la mondialisation
libérale or les grands enjeux tels
qu'ils se présentent à nous aujourd'hui
une mondialisation devenue folle des
inégalités de patrimoine qui explosent
des fractures sociales territoriales et
bien sûr au dessus de tout ça la
question écologique le changement
climatique eh bien ça mériterait un
véritable travail un véritable programme
de gouvernement et c'est quand la la
gauche de gouvernement aura fait
significativement ce travail là qu'elle
pourra à nouveau espérer être
majoritaire et gouverner vous aurez
goûté tout ce qui vient d'être dit
françois hollande est ce qu'il y a une
responsabilité
du parti socialiste
2 au cours de ces dernières décennies et
de vous mêmes puisque vous avez été un
responsable du parti socialiste dans la
montée de jean-luc mais leurs jours
c'est à dire que vous n'avez vous
n'auriez pas été assez claire sur les
thèmes régalien par exemple moi je ne
crois pas qu'à côté de jean luc
mélenchon soit due à une insuffisance de
prise en compte des thèmes régalien ça
c'est non c'est pas la bonne explication
je crois que la montée de
l'extrême-droite parlons clairement et
ailier une désaffection des classes
populaires c'est-à-dire de personnes qui
considèrent que au-delà de la question
sociale la question de l'identité acquis
sur la sécurité doivent être traités en
tant que tel et même s'il ya eu des
efforts pour le faire dans lé
gouvernement de lionel jospin et comme
dans les miens il y a eu sans doute une
espèce d'occultation de ce qu était là
l'aspiration de ces classes populaires
qui n'était pas simplement d'être
sécurisée sur le plan social mais d'être
sécurisée sur le plan de leur place dans
une mondialisation qu'il est bouleversée
dans une europe qui ne répondait pas
nécessairement à leurs aspirations et
c'est ça qui explique qu'il y a eu à
partir du milieu des années 80 cette
explication est juste une montée de
l'extrême droite et des catégories
populaires qui se sont détachés de la
gauche pour cette raison là et c'est la
montée de la gauche radicale a une autre
explication c'est à dire que c'est parce
que la gauche de gouvernement
socialiste n'est pas assez sûr de lui
claire sur son identité capable de
proposer non seulement de poursuivre par
rapport à ce qui a été un passé plutôt
glorieux mais d'inventer des solutions
pour demain et aussi de prendre en
compte la question de l'écologie avec
radicalité car je crois que c'est une
inspiration à ce même très forte de
talent de la jeune génération c'est et
c'est ce qui explique la difficulté qu'a
eue le parti socialiste est dernière
année et le défaut d'incarnation parce
que pour être un grand mouvement il faut
avoir plusieurs conditions la première
il faut un parti
la force du mouvement social démocrate
c'est d'avoir imaginé que la solution
devait être collective et pas s'en
remettre à une personne ou un mouvement
un moment d'humeur donc se construire
une formation politique qui pèse sur
l'ensemble du pipa simplement des
réseaux d'élus ce qui compte mais des
réseaux militants la deuxième condition
c'est d'avoir une doctrine une pensée
qui qui se renouvellent qui s'alimentent
et qui prend en compte ce que la société
elle-même produisent que c'est
l'intelligence individuelle ou
collective arrive à porter s'était
longtemps la force du parti social et de
capter les mouvements nouveau dans la
société et puis la troisième condition
c'est l'incarnation faut un moment une
personnalité ou un inconnu pour gagner
une élection il faut quand même un
moment que les français se retrouvent
dans deux derrière un homme ou une femme
et quand on n'a ni incarnation nino
catherine ni partie quand on obtient des
résultats recueillis ont été vos paris
j'aimerais avoir l'avis de même jour
froid sur ce clivage au sein du parti
socialiste 81 83
sur le clivage entre l'actuelle
direction et vous même qui représentait
l'opposition
est ce que finalement il y a une
responsabilité du parti socialiste qui
n'a pas su capter
l'aspiration des classes moyennes des
classes moyennes et des classes
populaires en réalité
il ya plusieurs il ya plusieurs facteurs
et à la capacité de porter une utopie et
une capacité à construire un forme de
destin collectif
aujourd'hui quand on est dans notre
actualité
françois hollande en parlait à l'instant
les questions d'identité sont des
questions qui sont en train de traverser
la société française le rapport entre le
collectif et l'individuel
lorsque l'on est dans une
désaffection assez profonde vis-à-vis du
vote par exemple des instances
représentatives dans nos villes
populaires l'abstention et est
aujourd'hui très élevé ça veut dire que
nous sommes à un moment où la défiance
est devenu tellement importante
vis-à-vis et de nos institutions
vis-à-vis de la capacité que nous avons
transformé la vie des gens que nous
avons à la fois la désaffection des
classes populaires qui se disent que
finalement les parties les élus ont peu
d'incidence sur leur vie quotidienne
mais les classes moyennes qui ne voient
plus non plus de perspectives et qui
sont revenus à des demandes très
personnel là où dans les projets
politiques on parle global nous sommes
aujourd'hui face à des revendications
personnalisé sur les questions et
jaugeant arriverai jusqu'à réponse à
votre question sur les questions aussi
je parlais d'identité de qui nous sommes
l'explosion des arbres généalogiques que
nous avons dans le pays le fait que
chacun essaie de redire quelles sont ses
racines montre bien que nous n'arrivons
plus nous apporter une parole de
collectif est donc aujourd'hui il ya une
nécessité d'un travail le travail on l'a
dit sur les questions régaliennes on a
beaucoup parlé d'économie de sécurité
mais avons nous réussi à toujours bien
parler de ce que sera
des enfants sur les questions
d'éducation de capacité à vivre ensemble
et c'est là que nous devons travailler
sous le quinquennat de françois hollande
ce soir les socialistes se sont
affrontés devant la france entière avec
les frondeurs notamment est-ce que
depuis cinq ans nous n'avons 2017 nous
n'avons pas tranché les grands sujets
qui nous avait déjà divisé donc nous
n'avons pas suffisamment travaillé sur
ces questions économiques sociales
permettez moi de demander un diagnostic
à françois hollande vous avez parlé des
frondeurs pendant le quinquennat
françois hollande est ce que c'est ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est la
victoire des frondeurs avec la nuit
baisse des fraudes au débat sinon beau
il était oui mais où ils ont empoisonné
un peu là c'était un foisonnant c'est le
mot vous avez utilisé et que vous
reprenez oui au sens où c'est un poison
lent oui
ça infuse et donc aujourd'hui ceux qui
s'opposaient à ce que je faisais avec
les gouvernements que j'avais composé se
retrouve derrière jean-luc mélenchon
mais autour de quelques grandes
questions la première grande question
c'est la crédibilité c'est vrai que
c'est tentant de faire des propositions
qui sont incantatoire à cet égard le
programme delà du ps est un programme
que j'estime infaisable inapplicable au
sens où si on prend chaque mesure en
particulier aucune de me gêne mais et
tout globalement elles rendent
impossible bien bien davantage encore
que ce qu'avaient tenté françois
mitterrand en 1981 qui s'est arrêté en
1983 la deuxième
différenciation majeur c'est la question
européenne bien sûr que nous avons
besoin d'enrichir venir d'engager la
construction européenne encore
qu'aujourd'hui
qui va faire reproche à l'union
européenne d'agir comme elle a agi
pendant la crise sanitaire où elle a
levé le tabou de l'emprunt qui va
reprocher à l'union européenne ses
positions sur le climat alors qu'elle va
elles vont bien au-delà de ce que nous
même en france nous sommes capables de
faire et même sur le cren même s'il ya
encore des divisions même si leurs api
s'y oppose mais on a besoin de l'europe
et là c'est une vraie différenciation et
qui peut-être remonte d'ailleurs à 83,7
c'est exact qui s'est reproduit et de
retrouver d'ailleurs avec le départ de
jean pierre chevènement à partir de 1993
et puis aussi au moment du référendum
sur le traité constitutionnel européen
de 2005 est une vraie
différenciation entre entre les gauchers
mais même au sein du parti socialiste
donc là dessus le programme de de la
nuque de jean luc mélenchon parle de
sortir enfin de désobéir quand on
commence à désobéir on n'est plus dans
le cadre et quand on est plus dans le
calme et qu'on a une politique
maximalisme est en hausse hors de
l'union européenne ce qui tout à fait
respectable comme position c'est pas la
mienne mais qu'il faut assumer et donc
sur ces grandes questions comme le
disait et là il faut clarifier et on a
besoin de cette clarification
je comprends tout à fait que certains
veuillent à l'aide dans le sens que les
frondeurs indiqué don depuis un mois
jean luc mélenchon s'est retrouvé le
chef mais je pense que nous avons
absolument besoin d'une gauche qui
assume ce qu'elle a été qui regarde
l'avenir et je crois qu'il ya
suffisamment d'épreuves qui nous
attendent pour que les solutions
sociales démocrates soient mises en
avant et qui avance et qui propose aux
français une solution car comme vous
l'avez dit ce n'est jamais la gauche
radicale qui arrive aux responsabilités
du pays jamais pour que la gauche arrive
à à gouverner le pays il faut que la
plus responsable quitte à s'allier avec
la plus radicale mais puisse donner
suffisamment confiance à l'électorat
pour qu'ils puissent choisir la gauche
nicolas baverez
deux choses c'est vrai qu'on a
aujourd'hui un paradoxe étonnant c'est
que la logique du vote utile donc la
logique électorale débouche sur cette
union est sûre ce programme qui est en
fait
celui de la nuque et que derrière on n'a
jamais eu en fait autant de clivage
différend sur la gestion de l'économie
sur l'europe sur l'écologie
savoir si on fait le choix de la
décroissance ou encore le le problème du
nucléaire
et puis effectivement sur une question
qui devient fondamental c'est la défense
de la liberté de la démocratie face aux
régimes autoritaires et notamment à
l'invasion de l'ukraine par par vladimir
poutine et c'est là que dans cette cette
tension va être décisive un peu au delà
du résultat de l'élection législative
pour l'avenir de la gauche française
[Musique]
ce n'est pas faute d'y avoir essayé de
léon blum mendès france
mitterrand françois hollande on n'a
jamais pu
constitutionnaliser en france la
démocratie sociale même si les rapports
sociaux se sont beaucoup améliorées
pourquoi cette résistance des
institutions à une modernisation
progressiste de la politique et de la
nation françois hollande
c'est l'histoire des mouvements sociaux
et de la gauche française c'est à dire
que la social démocratie ne s'est pas
construite autour d'un syndicalisme qui
aurait été celui de la responsabilité
il ya eu une indépendance plus ou moins
grande d'ailleurs entre les syndicats
d'un côté et les partis politiques en
l'occurrence le parti socialiste et il
ya une deuxième tendance qui a été
de penser que l'état et l'état seul
pouvait régler les grandes questions de
la répartition du partage du pouvoir et
des avancées sociales et de ne pas faire
suffisamment confiance aux partenaires
qui pourtant sont ceux qui dans
l'entreprise arrive à trouver des
compromis moi même j'ai essayé seyec et
conférence sociale avec un certain
nombre de grands accords
interprofessionnels de de refaire vivre
la démocratie sociale et je constate que
depuis 2010 est cette volonté de
consultation de concertation voire de
négociations s'est perdu d'où d'ailleurs
née raidissement de la société à travers
les mouvements qu'on a connus gilet
jaune grève au mouvement sur les
retraites et d'une manière générale le
peu de confiance que l'état accordé à ce
qui pouvait être une forme de partage de
la responsabilité donc la social
démocratie c'est elle prétend encore
agir
essayer d'améliorer notre démocratie
politique et sociale elle doit faire
l'effort de la confiance à l'égard des
partenaires sociaux il se trouve que
dans le mouvement syndical il y a une
grande évolution qui s'est produite
c'est à dire que longtemps la cgt
syndicat de contestation qui néanmoins
signé des accords a été supplanté par la
cfdt et que on a là la possibilité
d'avoir une plus grande ouverture à la
négociation dans les entreprises comme
au niveau interprofessionnel ce qui
supposera d'ailleurs que l'état ne
prétendent pas faire le progrès
simplement par la loi quand je vois les
programmes pas simplement d'ailleurs
ceux de jean luc mélenchon tous les
programmes sont une accumulation de
décisions étatiques alors même que nous
aurions avantage à faire surgir aux eaux
pures de la société par de multiples
moyens pas simplement à travers les
partenaires sociaux mais aussi les
concertation citoyenne et consultation
etc les revendications qui pourraient ou
les propositions qui pourraient
permettre de faire avancer le pays
d'où ce sentiment qu'il y a une une
crise de la reprise vous avez crise de
la dmr françois hollande vous avez
essayé vous même vous de faire rentrer
la démocratie sociale dans la
constitution et pourquoi ça n'a pas
marché d'abord parce que changer la
constitution enfants c'est impossible
sauf par référendum je ne vais pas faire
un référendum sur cette seule question
mais c'est vrai que je voulais que la
démocratie sociale soit reconnu dans la
constitution ce que ça aurait changé les
comportements ce pas sûr qu'il le faut
on pense que en changeant les textes
fondamentaux on modifie les pratiques
non c'est d'abord la reconnaissance des
pratiques et si nous ne le faisons pas
là je parle pas simplement de la gauche
si le gouvernement actuel continue dans
la lignée de ses prédécesseurs depuis
2010 est il aura de nouveau des
déconvenues assez lourde et assez grave
parce que les colères ce que disaient
aussi hélène par rapport aux
comportements individuels au défaut
d'application collective de manque de
représentation de mandat qui est donnée
à une organisation de signer pour la
collectivité tout ça aboutira à des
blocages qui sont tout à fait
préjudiciable et si on regarde toujours
les exemples européen là où ça
fonctionne le mieux c'est là où la
démocratie est la plus fluide et où les
représentants son armure venons en à ces
fameuses exemples européens
gouvernements sociaux-démocrates en
allemagne en espagne au portugal au
danemark suède finlande et c'est
pourquoi eux et pas nous voilà c'est un
peu cette originalité française elle
qu'est ce qu'ils empêchent en quelque
sorte je pense déjà que le problème est
celui de la définition à social
démocratie qu'est ce que c'est il ya une
définition large qui consiste à dire
c'est un horizon de transformation
sociale et l'émancipation mais par des
moyens légaux c'est la gauche non
révolutionnaire telle qu'elle s'est
constitué après le congrès de tours etc
définition plus précise consisterait à
dire au fond c'est une transformation
sociale appuyez sur les partenaires
sociaux et donc sur la démocratie
économique et sociale avec un rôle très
important donné à l'entreprise aux
branches et dans des pays comme le
danemark
la suède la social démocratie s'est
épanoui parce qu'on a un taux de
syndicalisation de l'ordre de 80 à 90%
donc que l'édile qui sont passés entre
les gouvernements et les syndicats
engagent toute la société est d'ailleurs
dans le personnel gouvernemental il ya
souvent d'anciens syndicalistes
il ya des allers-retours etc on n'a pas
du tout hélas cette tradition en france
on a des syndicats qui sont puissants la
cfdt en étant mais qui sont moins
importants qui ont une couverture moins
importante que dans les pays scandinaves
en allemagne or je pense que ce qui a
permis à ces pays de négocier le
tournant de la mondialisation tout en
gardant un fort modèle redistributif
haut niveau d'inégalité au danemark est
plus faible qu'en france
avant redistribution il est beaucoup
plus faible qu'en france on est sur un
rapport de dans la 3 qui a permis à ces
pays là à mon avis de conserver la
solidité de l'état providence tout en
affrontant le nouveau jeu de la
concurrence internationale et de la
modélisation c'est justement que ils ont
une culture plus pragmatique de la
négociation au plus près du terrain dans
les entreprises dans les branches qui
fait qu'ils ont négocié les protections
des security collectif de cette manière
on va pas inventer en france du jour au
lendemain
une culture de la négociation
avec des syndicats qui représentent pas
90% des salariés en revanche qu'on peut
faire c'est prendre la nouvelle donne
qui est celle d'une mondialisation qui
se rétrécit qui est celle d'une crise
climatique qui est celle d'une nécessité
de se réindustrialiser autour de la
transition énergétique et essayer de co
construire ce grand projet parce que ce
projet de transition énergétique et de
réindustrialisation en fait c'est un
projet national et c'est un projet
européen mais il faut essayer de le
construire avec des partenaires
socioéconomiques parce que des
transformations de cette ampleur
pourront pas être prises en charge par
la seule société politique c'est pas les
parlementaires ou les ministres qui vont
appuyer sur un bouton et qui vont faire
les transformations et ça c'est le seul
moyen à mon avis d'assurer la
résurrection de cette social-démocratie
qu'on pourrait rebaptiser social
écologie mais qui est par ailleurs et
c'est là le paradoxe
absolument nécessaire à notre temps
c'est à dire que si on n'arrive pas à
mettre en oeuvre ce programme de
gouvernement on va aller vers des
déconvenues des déchirures du chaos
social de l'anomie et je crains vraiment
le pire alors avec vous nicolas baverez
ce jeu à votre avis ce qui empêche la
venue de cette social-démocratie vous
l'avez dit c'est un pôle radical de
gauche néo marxistes mais vous pensez
également que c'est le populisme qui rig
à la fois aujourd'hui la droite et la
gauche qui fait de notre pays un pays un
peu rebelle à la social démocratie non
je crois que le
l'explication par l'histoire longue et
la fascination pour le radicalisme ans
et qui d'ailleurs joue aussi un peu sur
le sur la droite avec le modèle
bonapartiste donc le fait que sur une
large partie à droite comme à gauche on
n'aime pas la société civile on n'aime
pas la décentralisation ça ce sont des
tendances longues en revanche
l'explication par le populisme elle ne
tient pas parce que tous les pays
d'europe ont connu les mêmes choc ils
ont tous connu
l'arrivée le krach de la mondialisation
ils ont tous connu
des attaques terroristes ils sont
confrontés au réchauffement climatique
ils sont aujourd'hui confrontés aux
conséquences de la guerre en ukraine
partout on a vu de l'extrême droite et
de l'extrême gauche mais ça a mieux
résisté ailleurs et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que en europe on a des
cultures qui sont très très différentes
si la culture de l'europe du nord qui
est effectivement une culture très
social démocrate marquée par le
protestantisme
al'inverse on a des pays d'europe du sud
des pays méditerranéens qui sont très
très différents et c'est quand même très
intéressant de voir qu'aujourd'hui
effectivement portugal espagne mais
aussi danemark
suède finlande sont dirigés par des
sociaux démocrates c'est intéressant de
voir aussi ce que je rappelais segal en
dehors de l'union mais par exemple
chez les britanniques on a eu un moment
de prise en main de la gauche par des
radicaux ça a échoué et le lait beurre
est revenue pour une structure beaucoup
plus une orientation beaucoup plus
social démocrate alors comment est-ce
que ça peut s'expliquer ça peut
s'expliquer par le fait que je crois que
le il ya eu précisément chez eux ce
travail de remise en cause et
d'adaptation prenons l'écologie la suède
c'est le pays d'europe qui a mis en
place la taxe carbone la plus
intelligente c'est en même temps un pays
qui a réussi à faire de la baisse des
dépenses publiques de la compétitivité
mais aussi beaucoup de solidarité en
consacrant 4% de son pib à la recherche
aujourd'hui on constate également que
sur un événement parce que on parlait
tout à l'heure du régalien et c'est vrai
que souvent on considère que et une
certaine mollesse de la social
démocratie ba aujourd'hui c'est pas le
cas quand on regarde la suède et la
finlande aujourd'hui ce sont deux
premières ministre social démocrate il y
en a une qui est en train de mettre fin
à deux cents ans de neutralité de la
suède et l'autre également à la
neutralité depuis 45 ans rentrant dans
le temps ce qui est des dix minutes
après je vais interroger est vrai
tournant historique
voyez contrairement à ce qu'on dit la
social démocratie quand elle est bien
dirigée elle a la capacité à agir et à
tenir compte des grands défis qu'on a
rappelé l'écologie le problème des
inégalités avec un capitalisme
qui est aujourd'hui
dérégulé et
également répondre à un choc comme la
guerre de lier la dernière chose sur
laquelle je voudrais insister où il est
effectivement ces partis
sont restés extrêmement claires sur leur
engagement européen oui alors merci
hélène geoffroy vous vous êtes sur le
terrain et donc si je puis dire vous
m'intéresser à ce titre est ce que vous
êtes prête à ce tournant historique
c'est-à-dire à devenir officiellement
concrètement social-démocrate
pour prendre en considération les
réalités de terrain et ne pas rester sur
une pesanteur historique mais oui la
réalité c'est que je suis devenu social
démocrate en étant élu local ses
paradoxes peut-être parce que ce n'est
pas un concept que j'avais
particulièrement affinée avant d'être
mère et je suis devenu juste en deux
mots redire j'étais adjointe au maire
d'en avants vlan début ville comme d'un
maire communiste et aujourd'hui je suis
je siège est à métropole de lyon qui est
gérée par les écologistes et je suis
dans l'exécutif en tant que
vice-présidente et donc j'ai eu
l'occasion d'observer en étant
finalement minoritaire dans une majorité
d'union de la gauche
combien les utopies alors l'utopie
communiste la fin des années 2000 qui
était sur le principe finalement 2 je
caricature un peu mais on fait le bien
du peuple finalement et donc on théorise
ce qu'on doit faire comme action
municipale et du point de vue écologiste
aujourd'hui comme il faut sauver la
planète donc on comptera jusqu'à 1,4
toujours un peu denses et ont contraint
les comportements parce qu'elle
l'urgence climatique
et que tout ce qui relève d'un compromis
d'une adaptation est vécu comme suspect
et bien par ces expériences là je suis
d'autant plus devenu social démocrate
que je suis convaincu que nous pourrons
amorcé aucune transformation sans
l'adhésion des habitants et j'irai même
plus loin que la question des
partenaires sociaux parce qu'ils vivent
là même le même discrédit en réalité que
les élus c'est qu'ils ont un corps
électoral qui est faible où tout cas
avec d un nombre d'électeurs qui ne
cesse de décroître d'ailleurs vous
remarquerez que la seule élection
aujourd'hui qui attire vraiment ces
élections présidentielles toutes les
autres élections intermédiaires et les
élections syndicales ont des taux de
participation faible et donc c'est à
partir de ce que nous construisons
effectivement sur une partie de la
réponse sociale démocrate se fera se
fait avec les citoyens alors je dis bien
les citoyens parce qu'on a toujours
l'inquiétude de se dire est ce qu on est
dans quelque chose informellement au
travers de
consensus que l'on construit sur sur les
territoires parce que je crois qu'on
peut arriver à faire avancer des projets
de transformation transition écologique
qu'on peut arriver à travailler les
questions sociales je vois tous les
sujets autour des minima sociaux ce qui
est un acquis de la démocratie sociale
démocratie dire un moment on accompagne
celles et ceux qui ont des difficultés
mais qui se sont rendus avec le mot
solidarité qui s'est transformé hier
entraîne aujourd'hui du rejet dans le
pays on voit aussi donc tous ces
compromis qu'on a construit je pense
qu'il faut les repenser vraiment au nid
à partir aussi du niveau local et que
peut être ce que nous avons pu louper
nous les socialistes c'est que nous
avons pensé le pays
évidemment et penser les la
macroéconomie et caetera et pas ses
pensées le lien avec ce que ceux des
habitants sont en capacité de produire
eux-mêmes comme solution et je crois que
c'est la bonne échelle y compris avec
les entreprises un territoire fait le
monde économique et associatif politique
et celui des citoyens parce que nous
devenons devant et j'ai gelé la nouveau
être de nouveau dans le registre de la
preuve en réalité il nous faut re
démontrer à chaque fois quand tant
qu'institution quand nous proposons
quelque chose ça peut fonctionner et
c'était aller très loin avec les vaccins
sous me permettez cette assise là parce
que je suis scientifique de formation ce
qui m'a frappé c'est que alors que nous
avons une progression nous sommes dans
une société à laquelle presque tout le
monde était à l'école acquis un socle de
connaissances le rapport à la
connaissance à la recherche a été
comment dirais-je est devenu totalement
hystérique d'une certaine façon puisque
tout a été remis en question y compris
dans ce qu'on pourrait considérer comme
un acquis scientifiques éprouvés par la
recherche et donc on a tous ces aspects
là je crois à la fois de rapport à la
connaissance à retravailler de relations
entre les acteurs du territoire et tout
s'inscrit dans un projet évidemment qui
doit être globale parce qu'on ne peut
pas être que soit la série voilà un beau
programme social démocrate
[Musique]
alors on a souvent moqué et la gauche
socialiste ne s'en est pas privé de
cette fameuse troisième voie politique
mise en exergue par bill clinton tony
blair et gerhard schröder et auparavant
les gouvernements brandt wilson est pas
le est-ce que c'est pas la voie
raisonnable pour ramener la social
démocratie au pouvoir françois hollande
oui on a longtemps opposé le socialisme
à la française au social démocratie
européenne
à mesure que les socialistes français
ont gouverné françois mitterrand deux
septennats moi-même quinquennal lionel
jospin sous une forme de cohabitation
cinq ans
nous avons été plus sur démocrate que
d'ailleurs beaucoup de sociaux
démocrates certains même ont considéré
qu on avait même été trop loin donc
l'idée qu' il y aurait un socialisme un
peu archaïque qui serait celui que nous
représentons et et que d'autres seraient
beaucoup plus moderne me paraît tout à
fait spécieux ce qui est vrai c'est que
nous n'avons pas suffisamment reconnu un
certain nombre d'évolutions que nous
devions accomplir et faire des choix
clairs pour les citoyens que nous avons
entretenu une certaine confusion sous la
pression c'est vrai d'une gauche
radicale qui fait toujours le même
reproche à la social démocratie c'est de
travailler va le journal le vous n'êtes
pas à la hauteur de la promesse que vous
avez des livrets et vous ne faites pas
autant une forme françois rouan
permettez moi juste interruption le
journaliste que je suis se souvient que
même les dirigeants sociaux-démocrates
comme vous ont critiqué cette troisième
voie alors qu'elle réussissait quand
même à se maintenir au pouvoir et leurs
héritiers sont actuellement au pouvoir
non est ce que vous regardez pas tous
mais certains est ce que vous regrettez
pas si vous voulez d'avoir par rapport à
ces critiques que vous avez mises à
l'époque nos vis-à-vis de la troisième
voie sur la troisième voie blairiste
oui il ya des qualités imminente mais ce
qu'il proposait était assez loin du
modèle social démocrate
ce serait plus plus proche de ce qui
peut se faire depuis quelques années en
france de la même manière schroeder a
fait des réformes très importantes mais
il les a fait aussi avec le souci de la
négociation et du partage et dans le
cadre d'une politique qui lui a coûté
coûté assez cher ensuite quant à bill
clinton je suis pas sûr qu'on puisse la
parenté un social-démocrate et la suite
a montré que c'était pas si simple aux
états unis d'en revenir sur sur
l'attitude de traversons aujourd'hui
parce que ça a été dit il ya un paradoxe
en france d'avoir une social-démocratie
aussi faible depuis ils ont 5 ans et
d'avoir des crises qui justifie des
solutions social-démocrate crise
sanitaire a montré que c'était quand
même par l'introduction des services
publics de l'état de règles qu'ils
devaient s'imposer à tous compris sur la
question de la recherche et de la
science deuxièmement la crise climatique
appelle nécessairement leur maintenant
c'est le mot à la mode la planification
écologique qui reprise par part de jean
luc mélenchon et emmanuel macron enfin
dont on sait pas très bien ce qu'elle
reprendrait vint l'idée qu'il faut quand
même essayer d'avoir un projet de long
terme et pas simplement répondre à
l'urgence bon finalement c'est plutôt
une solution social démocrate à
condition que cette planification soit
pas autorité ou qu'elle ne soit rien du
tout comme c'est possible aujourd'hui et
puis enfin il ya la question de la
redistribution des richesses où on voit
qu'il ya des inégalités qu'on peut pas
forcément corrigé de la même façon il ya
sans doute le poids de la fiscalité mais
qui a ses contraintes et à la formation
des inégalités c'est là que que l'école
reprend toute sa place et quand on
demande qu'est ce que c'est qu'être
humain vos lames et socialisme
démocratique pas c'est d'abord et avant
tout la question de l'éducation et de la
chance ou des conditions qui sont donnés
à tous nos concitoyens et en faire c'est
ça qui est compliqué c'est qu' il faut
une politique que social démocrate je
pense que la crise climatique l'appelle
encore davantage à dans une société qui
est de moins en moins soucieuse du
collectif et donc il faut aller
convaincre un projet pour la nation de
ce que peut être une conception de
l'union européenne c'est arrivé à mettre
du commun là où beaucoup essayent de
s'en sortir par eux mêmes et on va le
voir très rapidement sur la question du
pouvoir d'achat si on ne propose pas un
modèle d'ensemble pour que face à
l'inflation nous puissions trouver des
corrections et bien on aura des
secousses qui sont extrêmement violentes
dans notre pays merci david jay z est
revenue je suis pas sûr que bill clinton
tony blair soit des modèles politiques
pour la social démocratie si elle veut
se réinventer parce que c'était quand
même des
passionnés de la financiarisation donc
de substituer les services et notamment
les services financiers à l'industrie
avec les résultats qu'on sait c'est hier
que les états unis et l'angleterre fou
contrôle de nicholas et les pics sont
encore plus d industrialiser que la
france ça a créé des fractures
territoriales et les fractures sociales
béante qui explique les catastrophes
politiques les bombes à retardement
qu'on a eue avec l'élection trump et le
brésil deuxièmement ces gens qui n'ont
pas du tout pensé la crise climatique
justement on est allé à fond les ballons
dans les énergies fossiles alors qu'il y
avait eu un moment carter aux états unis
notamment on aurait pu prendre une autre
direction et beaucoup de temps a été
perdu en réalité 30 ou 40 ans et puis et
certains socialistes français je le
redis scission a donné avec beaucoup de
gaieté la fixation des règles du jeu de
la mondialisation libérale c'est à dire
l'om s'est faire rentrer la chine dans
l'om sait et c'est ça ça a été des
catastrophes aussi qu'ils ont bon certes
permis une réduction des inégalités
entre pays mais qui ont déchiré le tissu
social à l'intérieur des pays
industrialisés est d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui même larry fink le patron de
blackrock dit la mondialisation est
terminée je n'irai pas jusque là mais je
pense qu'on va effectivement vers une
régionalisation vers davantage de
protections d'ajustement carbone aux
frontières
donc pour moi ça c'est pas des
références et ce serait regardé dans le
rétroviseur je pense qu'il faut vraiment
regarder faire un effort de lucidité
regardez ce qu'ils quels sont les crises
auxquelles nous faisons face et les
solutions de type social démocrate sont
probablement les plus adaptées je
voudrais dire quand même un mot sur la
situation française il faut pas penser
que la social démocratie en tant que
électorat est réduite aux acquêts
certaines vérités sont parfois dur à
dire mais une très grande partie des
électeurs sociaux-démocrates votent
aujourd'hui pour emmanuel macron alors
est-ce qu'ils le font par adhésion ou
parce que par élimination d'une offre
radicale de gauche qui ne leur convient
pas la question est ouverte mais il
reste en france un électorat très fort
social-démocrate l'historienne forêt
sourit aujourd'hui ce tableau offre
politique justement david janin pour va
conclure cette émission sur le présent
et je vais vous interrogé là-dessus
gouverner c'est choisir
disait mendès-france le lait jospin
parler du choix des possibles pour les
années à venir tout en gardant son
identité politique est-ce que vous
pensez que le social-libéralisme
d'emmanuel macron elisabeth bornes
teintées d'ailleurs comme ça a été
soulignée de planisme écologiques soient
compatibles avec la social démocratie
que vous représentez enfin la fois
françois hollande enzo froid je me
souviens c'est ce qu'avait fait willy
brandt si je ne me trompe pas en 1973 en
s'alliant aux libéraux pour gouverner
est ce que finalement
la résilience de la social démocratie
n'est-elle pas au prix d'un compromis
politique avec ce que représente
emmanuel macron
si vous voulez bien nicolas baverez pour
rejoindre ce qui a été dit c'est à dire
que a priori la social démocratie elle
correspond très bien ou aux problèmes de
l'époque la stagnation la lutte contre
les inégalités
le fait de ressouder les nations est
précisément de trouver des compromis
pour ce qui est des manuels macron je
crois que aujourd'hui d'ailleurs pour le
gouvernement de d'elisabeth bornes c'est
très compliqué de savoir quelle est pour
l'instant leur véritable leur véritable
au positionnement et emmanuel macron ou
leur accès encore des pas le label de
social libéralisme
je ne pense pas et notamment quand on
regarde
alors on pourrait dire qu'en matière
économique
emmanuel macron a été plutôt libérale
mais si on regarde son mode d'exercice
du pouvoir il n'est pas du tout
social-démocrate vous l'avez rappelé la
social démocratie c'est le fait de
trouver des compromis avec la société
civile de décentraliser on a rarement vu
un pouvoir qui était aussi centralisé et
un côté vraiment même un bonapartiste
donc emmanuel mme emmanuelle mac comme
emmanuel macron est un est un caméléon
qui est très très difficile à définir il
ya une part de social démocratie dans sa
trajectoire et notamment en partie dans
sa politique économique donc son choix
européen qui est sans doute le merci
nicolas barise mais je ne pense pas
qu'on puisse simplement le réduire toute
la social démocratie notamment pour son
mode d'exercice du merci hélène geoffroy
vous vous êtes prête à ce compromis est
historique après tout l'histoire est
faite de compromis oui et la social
démocratie on lundi c'est la capacité de
trouver les compromis pour transformer
mais le moment nous en sommes
aujourd'hui est celui de pouvoir
réaffirmé
l'existence
et la nécessité plus que l'existence la
nécessité d'une formation d'un parti
politique d'un mouvement social
démocrate je crois que c'est ce dont
notre pays a besoin parce que nous
sortons d'une élection présidentielle
qui n'a en réalité permis de trancher
aucun des grands sujets aux des grandes
orientations dans l'aria besoin ni sur
le plan économique mais sur plan
suffisament des idées ont été énoncées
je ne dirais pas contraire évidemment
mais finalement sur l'orientation la
perspective la façon dont on dit aux
classes moyennes et aux classes
populaires qu'elles peuvent se projeter
c'est ça que permet la social démocratie
et c'est ce sur quoi nous devons
travailler la radicalité n'est pas la
solution nous l'avons dit tout au long
de votre émission et donc moi je suis
plutôt attaché à ce que maintenant nous
produisions notre projet merci david ges
deux mots là-dessus je pense qu'il faut
réconcilier les français entre eux parce
qu'on a un pays qui est
extraordinairement divise
extraordinairement fracturée et il faut
qu'on trouve à toutes les échelles de la
société les moyens de se parler de
construire des compromis je suis un
militant par exemple de la
proportionnelle je pense que nous devons
avoir des contrats du gouvernement entre
partis regardez les libéraux les
socialistes et les verts en allemagne
ils partagent pas la même vision du
monde mais ils se mettent d'accord sur
70 75 points qui vont former l'ossature
de leur contrat de gouvernement on
aurait une vie politique beaucoup plus
saine si on allait vers ça alors
françois l'ordre dernier mot vous êtes
prêt à un compromis sur cette question
sociale libérale avec après tout
quelqu'un qui a été réélu président et
qui a été votre ancien ministre
je vais essayer de faire
et tout ça en très peu de temps il s'est
dit il y a bon nombre d'électeurs
socialistes ou sociaux-démocrates qui
vote qui ont voté pour emmanuel macron
et en 2017 et refaire en 2022 faute
d'alternative
comme il y en a eu aussi pour nom qui on
venait voter jean luc mélenchon pour
éviter que marine le pen puisse accéder
au second tour et pour autant je
reconnais dans ce cas dit nicole ben
havraise le vrai c'est à dire que la
politique qui est conduite par emmanuel
macron a pu un moment s'habiller mais un
moment très bref du vocable de social
démocrate mais est indéfinissable c'est
ça son problème c'est qu'on ne sait pas
dans quelle direction nous allons encore
aujourd'hui à la veille d'élections
législatives ne savons pas quel est
exactement le programme nous ne savons
pas exactement quelle va être la ligne
de direction le choix qui va être fait
sur un grand nombre de sujets qu'on a
évoqué et est donc c'est ta définition
crée d'ailleurs une forme de malaise que
nous éprouvons tous enfin ce que je
crois c'est que le compromis quand on
est président la réplique faut toujours
leur chercher comme d'ailleurs sur les
grandes questions l'unité nationale
quand elle se quand elle est exigée la
grande différence avec les régimes
parlementaires que qui est sûre la la
rave dans la plupart des pays européens
c'est que dans les régimes
parlementaires vous êtes obligés de
faire des coalitions et il est rare de
trouver des sociaux démocrates qui
gouvernent seul ou me ils sont toujours
avec un ou plusieurs partenaires en
france est très difficile de faire une
coalition parce que précisément
il n'y a pas là la composition de la vie
politique il permet enfin si on avait la
proportionnelle ce serait sans doute
souhaitable du point de vue de la
représentation mais aujourd'hui on nous
aurions une élection à la
proportionnelle là dans les jours qui
viennent faute de la structuration du
débat politique et de l'organisation de
la vie politique à travers deux grandes
familles capable de gouverner cinq ans
est nécessaire que les oui mais pour
l'instant nous aurions une élection
proportionnelle le pays serait
totalement à gouvernable françois
hollande entre nu planus s et le social
libéralisme macron bornes vous
choisissez quoi parce que les
téléspectateurs se pose la question
et bien c'est intéressant d'une vieille
formule entre la nuque baisse et
la politique d' emmanuel macron il ya le
socialisme bien on n'avait pas répondu
mais si j'ai répondu très clairement
c'est que les troupes ne sont pas là
aujourd'hui les troupes nous allons les
appeler à s'enrôler dès la fin des
élections légistatives alors merci cette
réponse qui a quand même sans sa part
d'énigme il faut bien dire contraire
c'est une clarté limpide c'est à dire
qu' on n'est pas obligé d'être avec
l'affection luc mélenchon pour ne jamais
accéder au pouvoir ou être dans
l'incantation et c'est à dire dans la
frustration qu'à chaque élection on
recommence parce qu'on la gagne jamais
ou dans le espèces d'opportunisme qui
pour l'instant ne débouchent sur aucun
du aucun élément fort d'unité nationale
je pense que nous avons intérêt à
reconstruire des familles politiques
peut-être qu'un jour elle puisse
gouverner dans l'esprit qui a indiqué
david chase merci à rejouer ou présenter
une brève bibliographie d'abord un livre
qui fait le point sur la social
démocratie alain bergounioux bernard
manin la social démocratie où le
compromis ça c'est la bible voilà c'est
la bible paru aux puf un ouvrage de
david jez sur le nouvel le nouveau bon
modèle français c'est le nouveau de
stemred y apparut
larry donc commentaires nouveau
testament vient dire françois hollande
nicolas baverez rays au dernier livre
celle alerte démocratique est le
principal ennemi que vous pointez c'est
le populisme c'est bien ça en un mot
c'est tout à fait ça c'est tout à fait
ça françois hollande vous avez publié
affronter chez stock affronter quoi en
deux mots affronter la crise
démocratique parce que je pense que si
nous ne construisons rien capable de
lever une espérance et de susciter un
retour vers la politique nous aurons un
populisme qui ne cessera de de gonfler
d'importance merci françois hollande
merci david ges merci nicolas mas vreizh
merci hélène geoffroy d'avoir participé
à cette émission mercier à l'équipe dès
le cp de l'avoir réalisé
et je vous laisse avec cette pensée de
jean yves le drian ceux qui ont vendu
les restes de la maison dans le cadre
d'un populisme dominateur sont les mêmes
qui anime et les frondeurs contre
françois hollande en 2015
[Musique]